quelqu'un va te tuer c
je m'appelle miles et voici l'histoire
de la pire journée de ma vie
nouvelle attaque de ce qu'ils faisaient
ce qu'ils disent ce qu'ils aiment
choisissez au hasard des psychopathes
des tarés ou des criminels et les
obliger à s'affronter jusqu'à la mort
alors ça faisait bande est interdite
jusqu'à ce que j'entre dans la partie
alors tu as peur ça y est
ils ont pissé ces trucs sur mes mains
ils ont ma copine
les psychopathes et c'est le but
arrête de me tirer dessus
il faut que je te tue épisode a dit
qu'il s'effacerait montbardoise qu'ils
aiment va nous tuer tous les clubs no
j'ai un plan
c'est carrément suicidaire au marché
j'ai gagné
[Musique]